I think it's very important to
distinguish between this kind of
reductionism as a research program that
you're not happy unless you re Express
say thermodynamics in terms of quantum
field theory which nobody defends that's
a straw man or whether you're talking
not about our research but what actually
exists out there in the sense of
entailment are the laws of
thermodynamics entailed by other laws
like elementary particle physics and if
so one can talk about more fundamental
levels or not the fundamental levels are
the levels from which the arrows of
entailment go up and it gives a sense of
order in nature which exists in nature
is not necessarily something that we had
understand though that we can actually
use there's no question that
thermodynamics is worth studying in its
own terms
and in fact as has often been pointed
out if you could follow the motion of
every particle in a glass of water you
would still miss the idea of what the
temperature of the water is the things
we're interested in are often at a
higher level but the question is whether
or not principles like the principles of
thermodynamics are what they are because
of deeper principles in there and if
that kind of statement makes sense as I
think it does then we have a sense of
what is fundamental and what is not
fundamental it's a question of following
the arrows of what explains what not in
the sense that we explain it but that
that's how nature works using the more
than failing which is interesting
because you mean indenting the sense of
the higher level description
are compatible with no any Martell we
actually mean completely describe Bob
right I think that is your right that is
the question the present I have is what
justifies the police that the lower
levels do entail completely everything
well of course we don't know that's what
we're trying to figure out but if that's
the way history has work I think there
is a reason why people are skeptical
about this and it's the sort of thing
innocent wrote about in that article
more is different and it's always voted
and that is that and I think you have
written about it in the article doers I
read on the plane here and that is that
a lot of the features of these higher
level theories don't seem to depend very
much on what's going on at the deeper
level for example in phase transitions
which you wrote about there are certain
numbers which describe how systems
approach phase transitions these are
so-called critical exponents and you get
the same critical exponents in a
tremendous variety of entirely different
contexts and it makes you think that
there are laws of face transitions which
are somehow freestanding and are not do
not require any deeper level to be until
they just are the way they are I don't
think that's right I think you have
bodies of formalism like the
renormalization group theory of phase
transitions or thermodynamics which
apply in a great variety of
circumstances but when they apply they
apply because of a deeper level that
says they apply here and they don't
always apply for example Boltzmann made
a tremendous step forward when he showed
that the atomic theory that molecules
are bopping around explains or entails
the laws of thermodynamics and then it
was realized that those laws apply in
entirely different contexts like as
hawking showed the surface of the black
hole as a certain temperature
but in all cases of where thermodynamics
applies we can show why it applies in
terms of the deeper level and it doesn't
only supply a black hole only obeys the
laws of thermodynamics when it's big
when it contains many Planck masses and
at the last instant before a black hole
evaporates the laws of thermodynamics no
longer apply to it I know I I said well
for example well no I think pepper
always is it exists because you have a
large system I mean that's where
temperature comes from to take an even
more trivial example the sum of the
angles of a triangle is 180 degrees and
it doesn't matter whether you make the
triangle with pencil marks on a piece of
paper or with sticks I mean all of those
are physical instances where you get 180
degrees you have to ask well why does
that work in each case the answer
generally speaking is because the
gravitational field on the surface of
the earth is quite weak so it doesn't
curve space very much I mean that's the
that's the reductionist answer to why
the sum of the angles is 180 degrees
because well but I I mean I have in mind
something I can't prove is true I claim
that the whole development of physics
has been in this direction which doesn't
really prove anything and that is that
they're really hard in nature
entailments I mean when you know the
paradigm is Newton shows that the
inverse square law entails Kepler's laws
of planetary motion
Boltzmann shows that the statistical
mechanics of large numbers of molecules
impales laws of thermodynamics this is
our bread and butter
look this comes up in a very practical
way when we particle physicists want to
build accelerators
and this was a big you know Anderson
testified in the Senate that we
shouldn't build the super collider
because there's no sense in which
elementary particles physics is more
fundamental than his work in condensed
matter physics and we had to make the
case and fail to make it that that it is
more fundamental it doesn't mean that
condensed matter physics isn't
interesting and it doesn't mean that the
condensed matter physicists should only
think about quarks and gluons but it
does mean that there's a certain quality
of fundamental naswinger own right
we lost that argument cyclic miss the
Europeans when it hadn't built an
accelerator so it's a very practical
matter I got dragged into thinking about
philosophy by this issue at the time we
were trying to get the super collider
finished and wrote a book because of it
it is the goal that we have in physics
it's the goal that's historically been
working out over the centuries and to as
you did in the massimo in the paper i
read to deny the existence of more
fundamental levels and less fundamental
levels really makes a lot of the history
of physics pointless again just with
respect to what we mean by fundamental
so so you spoke of entailment i think
but i think one could seems to me want
to capture most of what you said if not
all of it by referring to constraints
instead right so so quantum physics
constrains absolutely everything
thermodynamics doesn't know i'm talking
about principles that is if you discover
a principle like the principles of
thermodynamics or the principle that sex
ratios tend to be equal male/female yeah
you then yes why is that principle true
you might say it's a fundamental law of
life that organisms that have sexual
reproduction tend to have equal numbers
of males and females but in fact we
don't we're not happy with that we try
to explain it in terms of a deeper level
which
evolutionary biology and which is in
turn you know why do why does evolution
work will we explain that in terms of
mutations and natural selection very
often we can't do the whole job because
historical accidents intervene which we
by definition we can't explain but I'm
not saying simply the quantum field
theory constrains everything I'm saying
that wherever you find a principle at
any level a statement about I mean for
example if in the kind of chemical or
biological phenomena you are talking
about whatever constraint you have
certain things are always true or for
certain kinds of constraints certain
other things are always true then you
it's a general principle you have to
explain them the explanation will always
be in certain terms of something more
fundamental I I try to use the word
entail rather than explain because
explain we can't really do that's always
I think that's that's raising on that
that's confusing actually I mean I think
that there's a formal sense of
entailment which you could probably
develop well sounds in which the arrows
point forwards but I'm trying to get a
more explanation I'm trying to get away
from that positivistic point of view
that if you don't have if you don't
really realize it then you're talking
about metaphysics I think there really
is out there he a set of fundamental
laws and anywhere else you find
principles they are what they are
because of those fundamental
you